She was an exotic dancer in Paris at the height of the bell park.
She was the object of sexual desire for wealthy men ambassadors and high ranking
officers. She was matter, Harry, the dancer, the spy,
one of the great names of world war I espionage novels, movies,
even video games,
and a young Indiana Jones episode have channeled a character that is now the
stuff of legends, a threw manipulative,
Al spying and double crossing on both Germany and the allies at the height of
world war.
I motivated only by greed and the need to maintain an extravagant lifestyle.
She was margarita.
Vaal also known as Matt Harry also known as agents age 21
of the German secret service.
She was accused of causing the death of 50,000 French soldiers and met her
deserved fate in front of a firing squad on a cold October morning in
1917.
But before you pronounce your verdict,
stop and think in a world of spies, nothing is as it seems,
the commonly accepted narrative of matter.
Harry May indeed just be a fabrication, which she really,
the ruthless double agents, the French counter espionage wanted you to believe,
or was she simply a porn on the European chess board lost in a game that
she could barely understand documents recently,
declassified by the French secret services reveal a whole new truth,
which well we're about to tell matter.
Harry was born margarita guru de Zel on the seven month of August, 1876.
She was born in the town of Lou of war to a relatively well off family.
Her first years of life,
they were literally uneventful until the day when age 13, her beloved father,
Adam abandoned her and her mother to live with another woman. Two years later,
her mother Andia died with no other sustenance.
Margarita was sent away by relatives to study, to become a teacher.
Margarita was now 15 and had bloomed with her dark complexion and exotic looks.
She stood out like an ort among dandy lions. That was according to a schoolmate.
This friend was not the only one to notice. Age 16.
Margarita was expelled from school for having an affair with the head and master
two years later,
she was living in the ha miserable and yearning for an adventure away from the
Netherlands. She found a way out through a lonely hearts,
advert posted by a Dutch colonial officer of Scottish descent.
Captain Rudolph McLeod, who was 22 years, a senior.
They married in July of 1895.
If margarita wanted adventure in life McCloud would offer it.
He was posted to the Dutch colonies in I year and things. Well,
they didn't really get much more exotic than that.
They married life in Indonesia though. It was not a happy one.
McLeod was a serious adult Herer and physically abusive.
She resorted to having numerous affairs with young officers posted in the
colony.
But the worst thing was that Rudolph had contracted syphilis by one of his
mistresses infecting margaritas by hereditary transmission, their two children,
Norman John and Louis Jean who had been born in 1896 and
1898 Norman's case. It was severe.
And he received the only available treatment at the time that was mercury.
The local doctor overdose the child who sadly died from mercury poisoning aged
only two. This was the final blow for the McCloud's marriage. They separated.
And after returning to the Netherlands in 1902, they formally got divorced.
A divorced woman like margarita in the early 20th century would have been at a
tremendous disadvantage, but she did not surrender in her colonial days.
She had picked up more than just an SD D from that gentleman, McLeod.
She could also speak fluent German, French, Italian, Spanish, and Malay.
Most of all, she could dance.
She had learned some local Malay and Indonesian dances unknown to European
audiences of the early 19 high hundreds.
And this is where her career truly started.
Imagine the setting it's Paris during the bell park,
a period that lasted from 1871 to 1914 in which French economy
culture and the arts were flourishing. The scene, the GME museum,
Asian art enter an unknown dancer who is going to Stu high society of Paris with
her bowl moves inspired by the mysterious rituals of the far east.
Her name used to be margarita McLeod, but now it's just Matta Harry,
the eye of the Dawn in the Malay language.
It was the start of a Stella career that would take her from private parties to
the most celebrated theaters in Europe. In fact,
Matta Harry's shows would've been completely banned in any other context,
even by the loose standards of the bell park,
she would perform with loose and transparent robes.
Very often stripping almost completely naked.
And yet she always got her way by stating that she was simply reenacting the
sacred dances of the prosthesis of some culture.
Another that was in Indonesia during the following year.
Her celebrity grew not only because of that performances,
but mainly of the affairs and the gossip that surrounded her,
her patrons included journalists, lawyers, governments, officials,
army officers, the top echelon of Paris society.
And they repaid her favors in lavish gifts, cloth jewels,
or just plain cash. Now it's so that we dispel a myth.
That's always surrounded Matt Harry,
the fact that she was little more than prostitute and had an appetite for sex
with powerful men in a series of letters to our cousin,
Edward published in 2017, that Harry confesses,
how she had developed a loathing for sex after her unfortunate relationship with
McLeod, if sometimes she consented to a relationship with a powerful friend,
it was only so that she could provide for her beloved daughter, Louise.
It was a fact nonetheless that her dancing had made her famous,
but it was her wealthy acquaintances that had made her rich.
These acquaintances became ever more important with time as the bell park
gradually slid into the warning signs of the war to end or wars demands for her
shows, it started to wane in June of 1914,
she had received an offer to dance in Berlin. It was too good,
an opportunity to miss. Unfortunately,
the show was canceled due to a small mishap gem declaration of war against
Russia. On the 1st of August, this many was be matter, Harry,
to go back to Paris ALA though another small thing prevented her from doing so.
And that was Germany's declaration of Oregon, France on the 3rd of August. Yep.
World war I that had begun.
Matt Harry decided then to return to a real home for Hague,
she could have settled there and enjoyed a quiet life in one of the few
remaining neutral powers of Europe. She could on that, but she didn't.
It was in the autumn of 1915, the Matt Harry started dating one. Carl Cromer,
apparently the honorary cons of Germany and Amsterdam,
but actually an agent for the Kaiser secret service Cromer had a plan.
He would recruit this beautiful woman who carried a neutral passport and spoke
several languages to seduce top brass in the allied fields in report back
any secrets she could gather her reward, 20,000 Franks.
This is when accounts start to differ.
According to the official inquiry that would follow.
This is when Matt Harry officially became agent H 21 and started our aim
to harm the allied war effort for the sole reason of earning more and more cash
to fund lavish lifestyle, feel free to believe the legends,
but the declassified documents, they suggest a rather different story matter.
Harry declines the offer, but she kept the 20,000 Frans in her eyes.
This was rightful compensation for having her furs and jewels seized by German
border guards at the outbreak of the war,
having regained some funds and some confidence.
Matt Harry returned to her spiritual home of Paris,
sailing to France from the Netherlands. In December of that year,
her ship was docked in the English port of Folkston and all passengers.
They were questions by a British intelligence officer.
The officer noted a matter, Harry. She speaks French English, Italian, Dutch,
probably German handsome, bold type of woman,
well and fashionably dressed and the final verdict, not above suspicion.
And she should be refused permission to return to the UK.
This overzealous officer even sent a message about Matta Harry to the French D
bureau or second office,
which was the counter espionage unit of the ministry of war headed by captain
George lado. It was January of 1916.
Now Matt Harry was back in Paris and had resumed her old habits,
hanging out with dashing officers and powerful under secretaries,
but something had changed. She was being followed Lao's agents.
They shadowed her every move, opened her mail and intercepted her phone calls.
I'm gonna present again, both versions of this ladies and gentlemen of the jury.
According to the official inquiry,
the counter espionage unit was gathering intelligence on matter,
Harry spying for the Germans,
but the facts are that the evidence they collected amounted to nothing
That same year Matta Harry met Vladimir mass love, probably her first love.
And certainly the greatest of her life.
DEMA love was a decorated Russian captain who had been partially blinded in one
eye while fighting on the Western front. When Vladimir proposed Matta,
Harry accepted happily, but he had to leave for the front again.
And how could she stay close to him?
Despite her passport from a neutral country, Matta Harry needed a special,
safe conduct to travel near the front lines.
And this is where Jean hello and ex lover enters the picture.
Jean apparently worked for the war department, but unofficially,
he was reporting to captain Ladu.
Jean arranged for an appointment for Matt Harry to meet the Dem Euro.
And the captain placed his offer on the table.
The exotic dancer would become a spy for them.
Seducing high ranking German targets in neutral countries to capture military
secrets in exchange,
captain Ladu would give her the safe contact she needed and also a million
Franks, by the way,
that's more than 3 million American dollars in today's money.
This would've been more than enough to support mass love herself after they
married,
especially if he did not recover his sight or his aristocratic family disowned
him.
Laue instructed Matt Harry to wait for instructions before going back to the
Hague via Spain. These were instructions though, that never came.
She did not know what intelligence she was meant to gather whom to targets nor
how to communicate in secret tired of waiting.
She eventually wrote him by regular post asking at least for an advance.
If she was going to seduce an important man, she needed to buy some new clothes.
Finally on route for Spain matter, Harry ship was yet again,
stopped at a British port and she was questioned once more. This time,
the British transferred her to London and kept her under custody until November
of 1916 is what was going on. Well,
it seems that the British secret service and I far I were trying to establish if
she was indeed margarita Zel, AKA matter,
Harry or one Clara Benedicts and actual German secret agents.
This was a sticky situation,
which Matt Harry tried to resolve by admitting to being a French agent,
the British contacted Ladu and his reply was understand nothing.
Send Matt Harry back to Spain. So what we is his game? Well,
according to the,
or pat Shipman MiFis interpretation was that Laue suspected her for some time of
being a German agent and had only pretended to employ her.
He would've been only too happy to have the Brits get rid of her,
but also on this occasion, they let her go in December of 1916 matter,
Harry set to work in Madrid, without instructions determines to win her reward.
She seduced a German diplomat major Arnold Vaka.
They spent only three afternoons in bed, but it was enough.
He let it slip that the German Navy with the Ottoman allies were planning as
submarine landing in Morocco, which was then a French colony,
the Germans planning to open a new front in north Africa. Well,
this was huge news to Harry sent a message to LA do to inform him and his
response. So why did lado not respond to her?
Did he not trust her or the intelligence that she had captured while matter,
Harry,
she sought advice from another lover this time a French officer Colonel Joseph
dove dove asked her to extract more information about the Moroccan landing from
Carl, which she did was a bad move.
Karl and the Germans now became suspicious and decided to act American
journalist Ross Warren,
how in 1985 claimed to have access to the matter Harry dossier,
which had been couch secret by the museum bureau since 1917.
According to him what the German secret service did was incredibly sneaky
suspecting that Matt Harry was a French spy and still resentful that she had
extorted 20,000 Frans from Kramer in 1915,
Carl and his cronies sent a secret radio message to Berlin to get rid of that.
This message implicated the matter Harry was actually a German to agent,
but the evil genius part was that they used a code,
which they knew the French had already cracked.
The message was intercepted by a listening post located on top of the eel tower.
I mean, it is a big area after all.
And this was promptly relayed to led do who now had the evidence that he needed
to arrest Matt Harry? So the German agents,
they had manipulated a do into doing their own dirty work,
but Laue was only too happy to have been manipulated.
He had suspected her from the start and the French public opinion was always on
the hunt for scapegoats after the disastrous battles of the Psalm and Vidal in
January of 1917, Matt Harry to Paris and demanded to meet lado,
to claim her reward,
but he simply shuns her and she was running outta money and running out of hope.
Then on the 19th of February,
the DM bureau issued an arrest warrant against her.
The charges were espionage on behalf of Germany,
Matt Harry was taken to Salazar. Paris' harshest, women's prison.
She who had once been at home in some of the most Lux hotels of Europe now had
to survive in a flee ridden and overcrowded jail for three months.
She was interrogated by investigative magistrate,
Pierre Buson and unforgiving man with a prejudice against so-called loose
women. Like matter Harry, during this time Laue kept her completely isolated,
especially from her lawyer. Kue another ex lover runs from her fiance,
Vladimir a Massof finally on the 24th of July matter.
Harry went on trial once one of the most beautiful women in Europe,
she appeared ill, bloated and tired, but she was not defeated.
Cloe was not experienced in military trials, but he did a fair job.
He pointed out that the only evidence against her was the message in decepted at
the Eiffel tower may have been dotted by lado himself.
He produced a star witness,
the secretary to the ministry of foreign affairs who testified for Matta Harry's
good character and a loyalty Matta.
Harry gave a great performance pro claiming to the jury that a courtesan,
I admitted a spy, never,
but it was all a show trial from the very start a few weeks earlier,
the 20th eight April the disastrous navel of offense had ground to a halt.
40,000 French soldiers had died on a single day. The 16th of April,
as a consequence,
68 divisions had mu and eat in June refusing to continue fighting and dying
for France, the general public, they needed a scapegoat for these failures.
And what better could that be than a spy, even better, a foreign spy,
even better, a woman of loose morals, according to, or pat Shipman,
the seven jurors all believe the unfounded rumor that matter Harry's spying had
caused the death of 50 a thousand French soldiers.
How could she possibly standard chance against that? On the 27th of July,
the judge pronounced the verdict of guilty of espionage and treason.
The sentence was death to be carried out by firing squad.
On the morning of the 15th of October,
Matt Harry was driven to the Valson castle on the outskirts of pat,
six months of incarceration had taken that toll on a legendary beauty, even.
So she decided to wear finest clothes for the occasion.
The firing squad officer offered a blindfold her, but she refused. Instead.
She looked defiantly at her captors and her executors legend says that she blew
a kiss to one of the soldiers of the firing squad and one to the priest there to
offer her the law us rights.
Then the squad commander raised his Sabba journalist and eyewitness Harry Wells
wrote she did not die.
How actors and moving picture stars would have us believe that people die when
they are shot.
She'd not throw up her hands nor did she plunge straightforward or straight
back. Instead she seemed to collapse slowly, inwardly.
She settled to her knees,
her head up always and without the slightest change of expression on her face,
she laid prone motionless with her face, turned towards the sky,
a noncommissioned officer Drew's revolver bending over.
He placed the revolver almost, but not quite against the left temple of the spy.
He pulled the trigger and the bullet torrent of the brain of the woman.
She had tied Europe's richest and most powerful men to her little finger.
She had Europe's audiences at her feet buts when the bell park ended and the
water end, all wars had broken out. Matt Harry had failed to stay afloat.
She had been condemned by her naivety rather than her cunning and had been
framed by petty and vengeful men.
Yet she faced her last week's on earth with a great dignity,
giving her best ever performance on that cold October morning,
the Sergeant major supervising the firing squad remarked at the time by God,
this lady knows how to die.
So thank you for watching today's video and let us know your ver in the
comments. Do you think Matt Harry, a legendary spy,
or maybe just a martyr of a great game that she couldn't control?
If you wanna know more about world war,
I check at our video about Kaiser VI helm right here. So as always,
please do subscribe and hit the bell icons.
Make sure you don't miss out on any of our videos and I'll see you next time.
Thank you for watching.